I give Salam to my people in Bangladesh
Salam to the people of Marrakech
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care true brothers and sisters and dear
friends before our star wanna praise
allah subhanho wa taala the most
merciful the most trust or praise His
glory and gratitude belong him for the
works that we do as Salam will hear the
on the ground inshallah right behind me
is the school that all this happened now
there's a few points I want to mention
in sha allah for all of us to benefit
now we know exactly everybody knows from
media outlets
whoever's haven't happened here I was on
my way here I caught broke down I was a
bit late but um dinner I got here I cut
the response Allah
you know we plan and all our plans I was
the best of planners now what I want to
mention is that what happened is wrong
you know I don't need to go over that
and whoever it happens to is wrong we
want to make this very clear because
there's opportunistic people from the
far-right extremist groups like Tom
Robinson bring first and the rest they
are taking this as an opportunity to
make it seem like a young British lads
and girls are getting bullied but when I
say Muslim the media calls are crazy
now what one highlight is the fact that
no matter how it happens - it's wrong be
you a Muslim no Muslim whoever you are
it is wrong yeah and now the question
that needs to be asked is why did this
happen why did this boy because I
believe there's two victims in this the
boy who's bullying is a victim and the
one who's been bullied is a victim they
are both victim what a victim - now
Jamal is a victim to Bashar al-assad yes
in Syria his family were tortured and he
came here right he is a victim to that
then he became another victim to the
far-right and their propaganda
he's a victim to those two things the
guy he did the bullying the boy who did
the bullying he is a victim also now
what he did was wrong I'm not gonna come
here and sugarcoat it it was despicable
disgusting
whoever is dumb but if it's a Muslim
doing it to a non Muslim or non-muslim
doing it to Muslim it says wrong but I
have to be honest with you guys
he is a victim he has been glue
yes he has been groomed by who Fri
Tommy Robinson why because these
individuals the feel attacks that
happened
who's gonna happen by yeah the person
who came and run over innocent Muslims
what made this guy what triggered him to
go and do this so the frisbee park
attacks that happen why did it happen
because the same thing happened yeah
we're excited people as you can see so
did the guy who got caught he and his
letter he quoted to the Robinson yet Joe
Cox his murderer Thomas Mann he did the
same thing they are being brainwashed by
the far-right media and what are they
doing they're taking the matters into
their own hands because they seen
Muslims are our enemies and these people
and Isis are buddies they're business
partners now you're telling me you might
be asked me what are you talking about I
believe Isis and the far I are business
partners you know why because when Isis
Korea attacking kill innocent
non-muslims the far-right Tommy Robinson
in his comfy house his big house that he
gets hundred grand again he's got eight
properties
he's been funded well he's in his house
happy why is he happy because he's like
cuz he's like this is exactly what we
need to cause a riot a conflict this is
why he wants and this is the same thing
Isis and Jim Chowdhury people like them
do when the far-right Korea attack let's
say yes that's exactly what we need to
cause tension between the Muslims and
the non-muslims this is the reason why
their business partners they work with
each other and they love each other's
actions
I want to message given out to the young
innocent white British kids that are
watching this the very same Tommy
Robinson their very same Britain first
their very same far right and this goes
both of Isis as well yeah
these people who are in their comfy
houses Tommy Robinson in its comfy house
his kids go to private schools he goes
on holidays every year he's got a
property that he lives uncomfortably
when things gets messy and when there's
a riot happening Tommy's going to be in
his house with a sip of tea enjoying it
Wow you you young kids like you who
bully this boy or be those who
brainwashed but is extremists like Isis
when you guys carry out the attack these
people are in their comfy house is
watching it and seeing you get murdered
and seeing you get killed this is the
reason why my dear brothers and sisters
in humanity do not fall for this
nonsense
Tommy Robinson wants a riot he wants a
ride because he's got personal issues
which I know very deeply I'm not gonna
go into he knows very well yeah if I
open my mouth I don't want to get
personal yeah
now he's come and he's been lit through
this situation now what he's doing his
twisting his story and claiming that
Jamal was responsible for beating up a
white girl look at the situation look at
the words that he uses a group of Muslim
gangs including Jamal was writing and
beating this girl and the mother going
Carter well guess what on the screen you
can see the same mother of that girl
saying this is a life I never said Jamal
is involved do you see what kind of a
vile scumbag this man is when I met him
when I met him face to face the same man
who says there's a hundred and thirteen
verses in the Quran that says kill the
disbelievers I said how can you give me
one for one I was speaking to him not a
single verse ebook I want to wrap it up
brothers and sisters I urge non Muslim
Muslim who's watching this do not fall
for the propaganda of these viral
animals Isis and the far-right because
you're gonna end up suffering it's yoga
that's content of suffering and lastly
whoever sending death threat and
bullying the bully who was bullying do
not do the same thing and the mistake
he's done he himself is a victim to this
so all I'm saying is this what he did
was wrong but do not go sending death
threats and make him feel how he made
Jamal feel do not do that it's wrong as
Muslims the first asylum when he and his
companions went through torture and
slaughter Burroughs verse 78 unless want
Allah says we were seeing what they were
doing to the believers they did not
persecute them and torture them for no
other but they said our Lord is Allah so
brothers and sisters do not do the same
to this guy even though he comes from a
troubled background do not when he
when the Prophet peace be upon him who
conquered Mecca if the gave his enemies
so it's very simple
inshallah if you watching the shade with
your friends and family tonight in sha
Allah I'm planning on syndrome Al and
his family insha'Allah spending some
time with them hearing it from him
understanding him and actually Tamils
just wanna give him a hug
may Allah bless you guys for watching
assalamu alayka wa Metairie better care
- as-salaam we will always be on the
ground chuckling far right and all kind
of extremism wherever it is
assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh